bäume wir sitzen im auto auf den wegen
der ganzen unternehmen und steht die
übelste ps maschine mit argen
alle youtube quality labs ist ein
autofahrer machen
voerder wir sehen uns wieder wenn ihr
name angekommen und nicht nur mit
externen entwicklern wir müssen auch ein
kumpel abholen da ist hier irgendwo auf
dem parkplatz deswegen sucht meldet
jetzt mal bist du alleine torri
nur wenige minuten später sowieso nicht
dort noch etwas länger reichen nur
wenige minuten später noch immer nicht
gefunden aber wir haben gerade was
aufgebaut
2000 jahre später da elisa
wir sind
wir sind in ramsau angekommen dass
unsere busse da unten kommt man rein man
läuft hier quasi damit treppe hoch und
die ist nicht mehr fakten stellt man
hier also rein gefordert ist halt
schlafzimmer nummer eins ist aber jetzt
nicht so interessant hier ist quasi so
das wohnzimmer da sind gerade hardy und
tobi das ist unsere küche wohnbereich
quasi und hier läuft man dann halt
wieder seine ultra steile treppe hoch wo
man sich wohl spaß irgendwann mal und
ich mich nochmal komplett und dann kommt
man halt hier an und das ist einfach
wieder so einen schlafbereich alter das
ist so geil hier liegt einfach so eine
matratze drinnen auf dem boden und von
hier oben kann man quasi wieder so
runterschauen nach da unten das ist
megageil ja mir noch ein balkon und man
kann quasi komplett über amsterdam schon
ich hab noch nie haben wir gemacht aber
diese kurze es ist schon galt tut mir
leid dass irgendwie der technik stimmt
und die tonqualität scheiße ist aber so
besser dass sie als dass ich gar nichts
film ist also wir treten jetzt ein
bisschen vor und ihre nach dem club
wenn die bude gibt nicht die letzte
entscheidung gelesen dass ich der beste
blocker der welt bin
es ist 14 uhr 30 wir sind zwar schon
seit vier stunden später wachte ich bin
dumm und habe vergessen zu wollen
wir machen sich dann alle fertig alle
waren schon duschen ich sehe aus wie die
kuppel am hahn ist klar wie ich schwöre
ich bin ich weil ich jetzt keine ahnung
wieso ihr euch das an guckt unser klares
jetzt dieser dann schon fertig ich gehe
duschen sind in der stadt angekommen
also was heißt angekommen wir sind
eigentlich nur aus der tür raus gegangen
haben es salaam ist eine schöne
dingsbums stadtwerk mal überall so
kleine seitengassen überall so flüssig
blauem himmel sehr schön wenn ihr wollt
könnt ihr auch einen kanal abonnieren
also einfach anklicken und abonnieren
danke ich stelle jetzt extra die kamera
hier hilft wirklich jetzt gleich an der
kamera vorbei laufen
displays ist sofort in amazing als die
cm singh warum rede ich überhaupt auf
englisch und sondern vergessen und so
mittagessen besteht dazu man google
plattform und schmeißen 90 schweine auf
das nach alter was das thema plato
heilige scheiße
das wetter ist halt ein megaphon
schwarzes trikot
wir bedauern vorgeworfen hatte blogs in
scheiße weil ich einfach nicht locker
blogger
guck mal wie schön da mal wasser schon
mal der himmel blau ist schön hier so
froh dass ich alles machen da unserem
leben leben darf
extra bier gekauft ich höre aufgenommen
wie man jetzt spiele ich für meinen blog
ich ziehe meine schritte 1 2 3 mm hallo
ich will bloggen diese zu hause
angekommen also das heißt zuhause das
ist so diese meetings los spiegel
das ist scheiße geht wie chips seine
crew ich frei wie so dass der einzige
posten war
wir haben damit schon eingekauft und
bier und werden jetzt gleich und die
sonderschauen rechts am tiefpunkt dieser
schwarzen pulli kaufen dann ja noch
nicht so toll fresse ich bin ein bürger
sei es nicht so
wir akzeptieren es nicht die verstehen
es nicht dass ich mein leben mit euch
teilen und euch zu schauen ich bin
übrigens frau eigentlich meinen blog
folgen
vielleicht und virenfrei junges diese
kamera um schicht selbst bei myvideo
preis in der kategorie die werde ich
nicht gerne eingebracht
seit ihre scheiße ich kann mich auch
nicht außer trieren werden auf dem
videopreis eine kategorie die beste blog
denke ich wird es gewinnen das übrigens
unser aussicht also wir können quasi
hier noch nach unten dass der weg hallo
mein name ist friedrich mit der bau von
dem an ich glaube ich die beste bin ich
noch kaputt okay vielleicht aber nicht
gerade auf unserem balkon gegangen und
da hinten ist gerade sonnenuntergang pds
diesem sinn da hinten ist irgendwie
kirche blauäugigen wie sehen und da
hinten ist amsterdam überall hier halt
ihr ist es freunde bester blocker ich
schaffe es dann erst noch an der skala
von eins bis acht wie schaffst eines
anwenders skala von eins ist mein essen
war sehr lecker aber es war auch schaaf
wäre mir so ein inter bestellt und warum
müssen ihnen indien alles so hoffmann
ich bin blogger seid ruhig wenn ich die
kamera richte
der airline blockiert
es ist halb eins irgendwie ich nicht
mehr geglaubt ich habe keine ahnung
warum weil ich vielleicht dumm bin oder
so war trotzdem bester blocker aller
zeiten wir fahren jetzt mit einem u bahn
zum club
sind wieder zu hause angekommen es ist 7
oder irgendwie so geht schlafen dann
morgen
es ist der 30 gerade aufgestanden und
jetzt zahle doch eben alle drauf und
müssen eine halbe stunde aus der wohnung
raus sein und ich denke das schaffen wir
nicht
ich bin ein blogger erschloss sich
kamera hupen
wir sitzen im auto fahre zurück nach
köln brauchen angeblich zweieinhalb
stunden das sagt man doch so wenn man
locker ist nicht von ihren leiden teil
abonnieren
wir fahren hier weg oder es ist so
schönes wetter ab und in deutschland ich
sag's regel wieder dieses todes gleich
mehr ankommen vielleicht könnt ihr euch
noch einmal eine aussage von vorhin
erinnern und in deutschland ich sag sie
es regnet wieder dieses todes gleich
wenn wir ankommen wir sind in
deutschland und das wetter ist scheiße
wir sind auch in holland okay wir gehen
jetzt rein und holen uns was zu essen
kamera exakt eingestellt damit gegen
kohl und
halle kurz schnauze halten nicht locker
wir sind wieder in deutschland
angekommen da satten drei stunden
fahrten etwa unseres wetter ist komplett
scheiße aber hey was sind wir anderes
von deutschland gewöhnt ich würde sagen
das war es jetzt hier auch von dem blog
ich hab den ja auch irgendwo ich habe
ihn ganz anders angefangen ich würde
aber sagen freunde wenn es euch gefallen
anlass man leicht da das war kein
typischer blau ich kann mit links die
kamera halten habe ich dann die muskeln
das war es hier vom glauben freunde habe
ich schon gesagt lasst leichter
abonniert bei den kanal dann habe ich
mehr abonnenten
ach so was ja sagen wollte weil es kein
typischer blog wir leben vielleicht von
anderen youtube kennt aber ich bin auch
kein normaler mensch noch mal eine ganz
kurze sache an leute die jetzt
vielleicht denken dass ich das die ganze
zeit ernst meint mit
ich bin der beste blocker und gewinn den
videopreis damit unsere scheiße das
ganze sollte eigentlich eher so ein hoch
dem video seien irgendwie dieses blog
game wird irgendwie immer stronger und
jeder gibt sich da mehr mühe bei mit
drohnen und so aber ich finde ich bin
unterhaltungskanal und möchte irgendwie
das machen worauf ich bock gehabt
deswegen habe ich das jetzt irgendwie
versucht bisschen bescheuert witzig
darzustellen er läuft das gefallen hat
dann wie gesagt lasst einfach mal weg da
ich hätte auf jeden fall bock demnächst
irgendwie wenn ich irgendwo hinfahre
fliege oder so mehr von solchen blocks
zu machen weil dieses ganzen details und
das hat mir noch nie so wirklich
gefallen tarifeinkommen spielen maybe
next time to get a message for american
und englisch videos so alavi zeox spaß
ich habe keine englischen sprache als ob
ich überhaupt zuschauer